welcome back to the David Pacman show
and thank you for joining me I Am David
packman if he was turned into a pumpkin
at midnight and then somehow for some
unexplained spiritual and magical reason
didn't quite get turned back into
himself
I'm Jesse dollar I am the host of the
dollar more daily on YouTube and I doubt
it podcast wherever podcasts are found
it can also be found on the internet
on Twitter Instagram and Tech talk now
that all the Shameless self-promotion is
out of the way let's talk about a
Shameless stealth promoter himself
George Santos this entire Saga of his
committee assignments and the sub the
the previous lies that he's told uh have
kind of culminated and he just resigned
his committee assignments that were
granted to him by Kevin McCarthy and I'm
not going to take it I don't think you
should take it on face value his his
resignation from the Committees not
standing up and being there for his
constituency which has kind of been the
the Timber and the tenor of his of his
attitude up to this point I'm going to
read a statement but then before I do I
want to talk about exactly what is what
is taking place among the Republican
caucus it's become a revenge for hire
outfit the Republican party in the house
and they're going to exact Revenge upon
democrats for removing Marjorie Taylor
Green from her committees
and they're going to do it by way of
removing ilhan Omar not allowing ilhan
Omar to be on the Foreign Affairs
committee
for a number of different reasons almost
all of them rooted in racism rooted in
fear and bigotry and xenophobia
we're going to get to all of that I got
some clips but first I'm going to read
this the statement from George Santos
and we can we can talk about this and
and kind of break it down that this it
doesn't seem genuine to me this seems
like an excuse that he was forced off of
his committees by Kevin McCarthy because
maybe maybe Kevin McCarthy knows
something that the rest of us don't know
something that's coming down the pike or
just that this was too creating too much
complication for the Republicans in
their quest to punish ilhan Omar here's
this George Santos Republican of New
York's Third District issued the
following statement requesting that he
be recused from both the house committee
on small business and the house
committee on science space and
Technology quote with the ongoing
attention surrounding both my personal
and campaign Financial investigations I
have submitted a request to speaker
McCarthy that I be temporarily recused
for my committee assignments until I am
cleared quote unquote said Congressman
Santos this was a decision that I take
very seriously the business of the 118th
Congress must continue without media
fanfare
it is important that I primarily focus
on serving the constituents of New
York's third congressional district and
providing Federal level representation
without distraction too late bro
too late
it goes on I want to personally thank
speaker McCarthy for meeting with me to
discuss the matter and allowing me to
take time to properly clear my name
before returning to my committees to my
constituents I remain committed to
serving the district and delivering
results for both New York's third
congressional district and for the
American people
I don't think any of that is true I
think that he is being forced off of his
committees by Kevin McCarthy
um for a number of different reasons
well at least two I think this is my
estimation of it when I worked for for
the Congress back in the day I worked
for the United States Senate I didn't
really have much to do on the house side
but politics is politics and I think
what's taking place here is Kevin
McCarthy either knows something's coming
down the line that's going to force his
hand or he knows that this is
complicating their racist xenophobia
um mission to remove ilhan Omar
congresswoman ilhan Omar from her post
on the Foreign Relations the Foreign
Affairs committee now this was asked of
of Steve scalise a leader in the House
of Representatives a leader in the
Republican Party even though years ago a
while campaigning Steve scalise said
that he's just like David Duke except
without all the baggage Steve scalise
just like the former Grand wizard of the
KKK without all that baggage
I always like to remind people what he
said he is talking here about
congresswoman ilhan Omar and he put He
juxtaposes it against what Democrats did
to Marjorie Taylor green by removing her
from her committees for things that she
said before she was even a
congressperson watch this
committee
yeah obviously we've we've been talking
to our members and and pointing out a
lot of issues because you know if you
look at what we were very concerned
about last congress with Democrats
removing Marjorie Taylor green and Paul
goes are from all of their committees
this is not the same in a number of
regards number one they went after
Marjorie Taylor green for things that
she had said before she was a member of
Congress that she denounced before she
was a member of Congress it was very
personal and they removed her from every
committee even if Omar were to be
removed from the Foreign Affairs
committee she'd still be allowed to
serve on other committees so a lot of
dis big differences and if if Omar is
concerned about being removed uh
probably be good if you would ask her
why she voted to remove Marjorie Taylor
green and Go sir from their committees
because she did vote to do that
it's because of vile racism and
terroristic
um
goings-on relative to Marjorie Taylor
green not not full-on terrorism but
stalking hounding school shooting victim
survivors
uh going to the Capitol I'm going to
play a clip a little later of her going
to the Capitol to find ilhan Omar to get
her to answer why she didn't swear her
put her hand on the Bible the Holy Bible
not the Quran when she became a member
of Congress
it is a completely different thing this
is hypocrisy run amok again this is a
Revenge fantasy being fulfilled by the
Republican Party
now some of my suspicions I believe will
become your suspicions as well when you
watch Marjorie Taylor green being
interviewed what looks like in the in
the Crypt in the in the in the Labyrinth
beneath the capital by reporters and she
kind of spills the beans that
Santos needed to go because of uh their
quest to remove ilhan Omar watch this
that there was so much drama really over
the situation and
um especially what what we're doing to
work to remove ilhan Omar from the
Foreign Affairs committee Mr Santos
statement in there was just saying that
he he spoke with speaker McCarthy and
and made this decision on his own
they're doing a lot of work to try to
convince you that George Santos made
this decision on his own all while
crying crocodile tears about the prior
the previous removal of Marjorie Taylor
green for things that she said before
she was a congresswoman oh my God it was
so personal it was
and here's the clip I talked about
earlier her skulking through the halls
of the office buildings on Capitol Hill
seeking out people to answer for their
crime of breaking the law not it's not a
law that someone must put their hand on
the Bible when they swear into Congress
this woman so stupid so ignorant of our
faith Traditions or requirements lack of
requirements for Faith Traditions to be
a member of Congress that she thinks you
must swear on a Bible
to become a member of Congress watch
this
they signed that they swore in on the
Korean oh we have the Bible we're going
to talk about swearing in on the how to
swear in on the Bible with them and let
them know what our law says that you
can't swear in on the Koran so we're
gonna we're gonna explain to that you
know we're going to explain about how
you can't swear in on the Koran and
we're going to have the Bible and ask
them if they would swear in on the Bible
that we really need them yeah we have
the oath yep
but when they swore in it wasn't a law
yet right so at the time they saw it I
don't know I think at the time they
weren't that wasn't passed because it
wouldn't have been passed in a
republican control yeah so it was passed
after they swore in so they're not
really official I don't think
so let's go ask them to swear in in the
Bible because like you said well um
uh yeah it has to be the Bible Well
is not compatible with America yep
that's the bottom line
how can you say you represent women but
you support Sharia law
this is this is stunning Krueger in in
rare rare form
so certain of herself that it was
against the law at some point
to use anything other than the Holy
Bible to swear on members of Congress
were swearing on Spider-Man comic books
or Superman comic books this Congress
you can swear on anything
if I were a member of Congress I think
I'd probably put my hand upon the
Constitution of the United States since
you're also swearing an oath to support
and defend that document
she's a member of Congress and when they
act like all this was so long ago this
was before she was a congress person
this is like two years before she became
a congressperson she's a 44 year old
woman she's a middle-aged woman
skulking through the Halls to teach her
a lesson
and the unfortunate thing is they're
going to get their way relative to ilhan
Omar
who's just a just a woman trying to do
her job trying to represent her
constituency
by by all accounts a loving and decent
person who has a heart for Humanity but
not a Republican and she is now in the
crosshairs figuratively speaking for now
and they're going to exact their Revenge
not great
one of our sponsors today is mosh
whether you're at the gym on the go
between meals mosh protein bars are the
smart snack to keep your body and brain
fueled there's six delicious flavors
like blueberry almond crunch peanut
butter chocolate Crunch cookie dough
crunch each mosh bar comes packed with
12 grams of protein six grams of fiber
but also important nutrients like
vitamin B vitamin D
Omega-3s and only one gram of sugar and
160 calories I've tried tons of
different protein bars really you can't
beat the taste and the texture of mosh I
love these my favorite is the chocolate
Crunch simple satisfying now that I'm
back in the gym I'll snack on one of
these after a workout mosh is also a
mission-driven company with a portion of
all proceeds donated to support women's
brain health research through the
women's Alzheimer's movement at
Cleveland Clinic mosh is giving my
audience 20 off plus free shipping on
your first six count trial pack go to
moshlife.com Pacman the link is down
below